Hey guys, I've been thinking about the our intros and they just need to be snappier and stuff So I'm gonna leave the way and just kind of take my leave. Hey there. I'm Jason, baby Hey I'm Shawn Hayesolis, sorry, smart. Well, did I just hear you turn in the fellas onto a band called The Police? Boy, where would we be without you? No, no, you did not hear that. That's fine. No, you did not. Hey, by the way, classic Bateman,
大家好，我一直在想我们的开场白，它们需要更精简一点之类的话，所以我要带头，然后就当作是告别了。大家好。我是杰森，宝贝。嘿，我是肖恩·海耶斯。索利，聪明。等等，我刚才是不是听见你跟这几位小伙子聊起一个叫“警察”的乐队了？天哪，如果没有你，我们要去哪儿找呢？不，不，你绝对没听见。没关系。不，你真没听见。对了，典型的贝特曼，
why don't you just take a position before you even know what this shot is? Know the shot, okay? I don't, don't make me quote Glengarry Glen Ross here. But you know what? A, know the shot. I think he just did. Didn't he?
你为什么不在弄清楚这个镜头是什么之前就先表态呢？弄清楚镜头是什么，好吗？我不想，别逼我在这里引用《大亨游戏》。但你知道吗？第一，弄清楚镜头是什么。我想他刚才已经说过了。不是吗？
I guess I just did. But also like always be closing, but also know the shot. What is the shot? I was, I, Jason Willen and I were chatting yesterday the day before about, you know, I was, I went outside to my garage, the garage is separated from my house and there's a shingle from the roof.
我想我刚才确实说过了。但同时也像“永远都在成交”一样，也要弄清楚镜头是什么。什么是镜头？我，我和杰森·威伦昨天或者前天在聊天，关于，你知道的，我走到我的车库，车库是跟我家分开的，房顶上有块瓦片。
I was like, on the ground. I was like, what's that? Your garage has shingles, dude. I gotta get the vaccine. Oh God. And so I'm standing there and here comes another shingle straight from my face. I was like, oh God.
我当时想，在地上。我就想，那是什么？哥们，你车库居然有瓦片。我得去打疫苗了。哦天哪。然后我就站在那儿，接着又一块瓦片直接冲着我的脸飞过来。我当时就想，哦天哪。
I was like, oh crap, I gotta get a new roof. It's been like over 20 plus years. And, and then so I call this, this contractor guys. For Tracy in Wisconsin, a roof is something that is on the top of a building. Sorry. Well, I mean, if we're gonna do. No, thank you.
我当时就想，哦糟糕，我得换个新屋顶了。这都二十多年了。然后呢，我就给这个，这个承包商打电话。对威斯康星州的特蕾西来说，屋顶就是建筑物顶部的东西。抱歉。好吧，我是说，如果我们要这么做。不，谢谢。
Thank you, thank you. And so then he comes over and there's like my, you know, whenever it rains, it floods my driveway. And then he's like, we should fix the drainage under the driveway. So I got to tear up the driveway and the roof. And then I was like, and then it turned into that thing where you're like, oh God, and I have to tear up.
谢谢，谢谢。然后他过来了，然后我的，你知道的，每当下雨的时候，我的车道就会被水淹。然后他就说，我们应该修一下车道底部的排水系统。所以我得把车道和屋顶都拆了。然后我就想，接着这就变成了那种让你觉得，哦天哪，我不得不把……
Just do everything. Everything. And then I was like, is homeownership kind of a scam? Cause it was a lot easier to live in an apartment. Jason, do we have to ask the question? The obvious question is, are you okay? Dude, maybe you just have a really fat squirrel on the roof. Have you, have you, have you looked?
把所有东西都拆了。所有东西。然后我就想，拥有房子是不是有点像个骗局？因为住在公寓里要轻松得多。杰森，我们非得问这个问题吗？显而易见的问题是，你没事吧？老兄，也许你屋顶上只是一只非常胖的松鼠。你，你，你看过吗？
No. Yeah, it could, it could be a real pain in the ass, chubby squirrel up there. But it feels like, do you feel like, do you feel like you're unraveling a little bit? Me? Yeah. Absolutely.
没有。对，上面可能，可能有一只让人头疼的胖松鼠。但你觉得，你有没有觉得自己有点快崩溃了？我？对。绝对有。
Why don't you just go back, back to the trailer. You know, things were so much simpler when you had wheels under your house. Sean, if you tore down your house and you put a nice big trailer on the property, I would. Who was, why not? Love that. Then they could, then, then Scotty could knock on the door
你为什么不直接回，回到拖车去呢。你知道，当你家底下还有轮子的时候，事情要简单得多。肖恩，如果你把你家拆了，在宅基地上放一辆漂亮的大拖车，我愿意。谁会，为什么不呢？太棒了。然后他们就可以，然后，斯科特就可以敲门
and say we're ready for you in five. Wasn't that, was, Dax was living in a trailer while, while he and Kristen were doing the house, right? Yeah. Well, he bought that crazy huge trailer. You saw it. And, and he's got that awesome trailer. And then he had it parked in front of the house,
然后说我们五分钟后就准备好。难道不是吗，当时，戴克斯住在拖车里，当他和克里斯滕在弄房子的那段时间，对吧？对。嗯，他买那个疯狂巨大的拖车。你看到了。而且，他有那个超棒的拖车。然后他把它停在房子前面，
in his nice house. And then like, Yeah. And it's a real, it's a real nice house. Mr, Mr. Keep It Real Detroit. Oh yeah. Living, living in a palace now. Thank you for calling him out on that.
在他那栋漂亮的房子前面。然后就像是，对。而且那是一栋非常非常漂亮的房子。底特律“保持真实”先生。哦对。现在住在宫殿里。谢谢你当面拆穿他。
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Old lifestyles of the rich and nailing it. Yeah. That'd be a great show. It sells itself. He would, he would be a great new host
好吧。对。对。富豪生活旧风貌，干得漂亮。对，那会是个很棒的节目。它自己就能卖出收视率。他会，他会成为一个很棒的新主持人
if, if they were going to redo that, that, that series of lifestyles of the rich and famous. What was his name? Robin. Robin Leach. Leach. Yeah. This is Robin Leach.
如果，如果要重拍那个系列的话，《富豪与名流的生活》。他叫什么名字？罗宾。罗宾·里奇。里奇。对。这是罗宾·里奇。
I'd love to see Dax hosting that show. It'd be like a cross between Cribs and. And Punk. Lifestyle. Yeah. Cause you, you know, Dax, he'd go through the house with the people and be like, you've got a greenhouse here.
我很想看到戴克斯主持那个节目。那感觉就像是《明星豪宅秀》和《明星大整蛊》的结合体。生活方式。对。因为你，你知道的戴克斯，他会和人们一起走过房子，然后说，你这里有个温室。
How much did you pay for that? That looks really, and the person would be on the spot. They'd be like, I don't know. And he goes, that's gotta be, I mean, those things go minimum million dollars. Minimal. Right?
你为这个花了多少钱？这看起来真的，然后这个人就会当场被问住。他们会说，我不知道。然后他会说，这肯定，我是说，这些东西起码要一百万美元。起码。对吧？
That's pretty good. The guys, ladies and gentlemen, Dax Shepard just stepped in for a second. Thank you. Aw, thanks, Sean. So I get this wonderful email from this fellow who you're about to say hello to. And in the email.
这挺不错的。各位，女士们先生们，戴克斯·谢泼德刚刚加入了一会儿。谢谢。哦，谢谢，肖恩。所以我收到了这位朋友发来的一封精彩邮件，你们马上就要跟他打招呼了。在这封邮件里。
Wait, are you getting to the guest? Is this you getting to the guest? Yeah, do you want to, what else do you want to bring up? It's pretty smooth. No, it was pretty smooth. Okay. Four minute wait for the guest is, is, was pretty, not bad.
等等，你要聊到嘉宾了吗？这是你准备引出嘉宾吗？对，你想，你还想提什么？挺顺畅的。不，这挺顺畅的。好吧，为嘉宾等了四分钟，挺，挺不错的，不算太糟。
So no, so you're going to say hi to this guy in just a second. And, and I got an email from him. Shall we make a stop? I'd love that we keep making references to the dresser. Stop that train. Do it, give me one will. Stop. Shall we make a stop?
所以不，所以你马上就要跟这家伙打招呼了，而且，我收到了他的一封邮件。我们要不要做个定格？我太喜欢我们不断提到那部电影《化妆间》了。停下那列火车。来吧，给我来一个。停。我们要不要做个定格？
I've never seen it. I don't know it. I have to, Tom Courtney is- I'm going to write this down. Perfection in that point. That's Tom Courtney starting to dress, Albert. What's it called? The dresser.
我从没看过。我不知道。我得把汤姆·科特尼是——我要把它记下来。那一刻简直完美。那是汤姆·科特尼在《化妆间》里演阿尔伯特。那叫什么？《化妆间》。
It's a classic. All right. Have you guys seen whatever happened to Baby Jane? All right, listen, in the email this guy- Oh, and there's a great new band called the police. Sorry, go ahead. And in the, in this email, this guy says to me, and he's so nice.
这是一部经典之作。好吧。你们看过《兰闺惊变》吗？好吧，听着，在这封邮件里这家伙——哦，还有一支叫警察乐队的棒极了的新乐队。抱歉，你继续。在这封，在这封邮件里，这家伙对我说，而且他太好了。
And he says, I know we don't know each other, except for some running at a doctor's office, which I'll have to ask him about. Whoa, wait, I want to get into that. Fine. But he says he's really good friends with you guys, and you would, and he would love to come on and surprise you. So to set up, oh my God, of course,
他说，我知道我们不认识彼此，除了在诊所偶遇过一次，我得向他打听打听这事。哇，等等，我想聊聊这个。好吧。但他说是你们的好朋友，而且他很想来上节目给你们一个惊喜。所以为了铺垫，哦天哪，当然，
it'll be a great excuse for the guys to say hi to you and for me to get to know you. Dax Shepherd doing a repeat performance. No, no, no. Dax is back. So like always, as soon as I describe who this person is, you're going to guess who it is because you played golf with him. But now just humor me and let me get out some of his credits
这对于你们几个跟他打招呼以及我来了解他会是个绝佳的借口。戴克斯·谢泼德在进行重播表演。不，不，不。戴克斯回来了。所以就像往常一样，我一描述这个人是谁，你们就会猜到他是谁，因为你们跟他一起打过高尔夫。但现在请迁就我一下，让我先介绍一下他的一些代表作
before you start boring me to tears with, which I earned your chance. Charlie Day. Yeah, I was going to say, is it Charlie? So Rob McLaney. This guy played Mac for 14 seasons on It's Always Sunny and Phil Duff. Rob McLaney.
在你们开始用那些我早就赢得的机会把我烦死之前。查理·戴。对，我刚想说，是查理吗？罗布·麦克尔亨尼。这家伙在《费城永远艳阳高照》里扮演了14季的麦克，还有《神话任务》。罗布·麦克尔亨尼。
He's on a new show called Miss Rob. Let's go. Just take the, take, take the thing. There he is. No way, Rob McLaney. Hi guys. Hi, Rob. Rob, look at your skin.
他有一个新节目叫《神话任务》。我们上吧。直接把，把那个拿来。他来了。不会吧，罗布·麦克尔亨尼。你们好，伙计们。嗨，罗布。罗布，看你的皮肤。
He has glowing skin all the time, doesn't he? Yeah. I mean, yeah. Your pale is all hell. Yeah, yeah. I'm exceptionally Irish. And so my skin is always going to be alabaster. Same.
他总是皮肤发光，对吧？对。我是说，对。你苍白得要命。对，对。我极其具有爱尔兰血统。所以我的皮肤永远都是雪白的。我也是。
Yeah. This is great. If I shave, it tends to get a little shiny. I've got a lot of questions for you. Luke, can we start with the listener? Do you know that Rob is the proud owner of a soccer team? Okay. I know.
太棒了。如果我刮胡子，往往会变得有点亮。我有很多问题要问你。卢克，我们能从听众开始吗？你知道罗布是一家足球俱乐部的骄傲老板吗？好吧。我知道。
Talk to me about that. I can't believe we haven't talked about this Rob at all yet. I keep meaning to ask you. And I feel like you know that I'm a big football fan. And then you've avoided talking to me about it. Is that true? Playing it cool. Okay.
跟我聊聊这个。真不敢相信我们到现在都还没聊过罗布的这件事。我一直想问你。而且我觉得你知道我是个超级橄榄球迷。然后你一直躲着不跟我聊这个。是这样吗？装酷呢。好吧。
Do you mind if I derail your own podcast for the first five to 10 minutes? Please do. Okay. I reached out to Sean because I realized that, yes, we play golf together. I don't know Sean very well, but I've played a number of rounds of golf
你介意我把你们自己的播客节目打断前五到十分钟吗？请便。好吧。我联系肖恩是因为我意识到，是的，我们一起打过高尔夫。我不是很了解肖恩，但我跟你们几位
with you gentlemen. And I've met you numbers of times over the years. He's a good player too. Yeah. I'm sorry. That's where you insert, but I'm a fan. But go ahead. Yeah.
打过好几轮高尔夫了。而且这些年来我见过你们很多次。他球技也很好。对。抱歉。这就是你插话的地方，不过我是个粉丝。但你继续。对。
I don't know Sean. I'm a fan. Well, of course. Well, we'll get to that later. Oh, thank you. Oh, thanks. Thanks. But what I realized is over the course of our relationships
我不认识肖恩。我是个粉丝。好吧，当然。我们会稍后谈到这个。哦，谢谢。哦，谢谢。谢谢。但让我意识到的是，在我们的交往过程中，
that while you're a very cordial and sweet man and wonderful friends, I'm fairly convinced, and Charlie and I have discussed this, that you have never seen anything, not one scene, not one frame of anything that I've ever done. And I find that to be quite amusing. Because I've never pointedly asked you.
虽然你们是非常热情亲切的人，也是极好的朋友，但我相当确信，查理和我讨论过这件事，那就是你们从来没有看过任何东西，没有看过任何一个场景，没有看过我做过的任何东西的哪怕一个镜头。我觉得这相当有趣。因为我从来没有直截了当地问过你们。
You're speaking to Jason, obviously. I'm speaking to both of you. I'm speaking to both of you. First of all, I have watched Mythic Quest. So F you, bro. Really? I know that your character's name is Ion Grim. Wow.
你显然是在跟杰森说话。我在跟你们两个说话。我在跟你们两个说话。首先，我看过《神话任务》。所以去你的吧，兄弟。真的吗？我知道你的角色名字叫伊恩·格林。哇。
Is the name of your character. I'm not even Googling. And I know that you guys, you run a video game company and then you're coming out with this new video. So please. And it's on Apple Plus. Oh yeah.
这就是你角色的名字。我甚至都没用谷歌搜索。而且我知道你们，你们经营一家视频游戏公司，然后你们要推出这个新视频。所以拜托。而且它在Apple Plus上。哦，是的。
Oh yeah. So yeah. I've seen it. You were impressed by that, Rob, right? I actually really was. The only thing I can surmise from that is, and still to your credit, I believe that this was all,
哦，是的。所以，是的。我看过了。罗布，你对那印象深刻，对吧？我其实真的很深刻。我能从中推断出的唯一一件事是，而且这依然要归功于你，我相信这一切都是，
you've seen this in the last, the show's been out for two years, but I think you watched in the last two weeks because you realized that we were gonna be playing more golf together and you had to make sure that you were, at least. A little bit of homework.
你在过去，这个节目已经播出了两年了，但我想你是在过去两周里看的，因为你意识到我们接下来会一起打更多的高尔夫球，你必须确保你至少……做了一点家庭作业。
Yeah, a little bit of homework, which I appreciate it. Now Bateman didn't even do that. You know what? It wasn't even that, like that sounds like something, that move is called a Bateman in show biz. But what I did was,
对，做了一点家庭作业，我很感激这一点。现在贝特曼甚至都没做到这一点。你知道吗？甚至都不是那样，那听起来像是个什么，在演艺界里这种举动被称为“贝特曼”。但我的做法是，
because since we've gotten to know each other, and we had a little bit of contact before, Rob wrote a pilot that I thought was hilarious many, many years ago, that was kind of came my way. At a certain point, there was a discussion about maybe, and I really wanted to do it,
因为自从我们开始了解彼此以来，我们之前也有过一点接触，罗布很多很多年前写过一个试播集，我觉得非常搞笑，那个项目不知怎么落到了我手上。在某个特定阶段，有过关于也许，而且我真的很想演，
and I forget what happened, and maybe they ultimately didn't want me, or something like that, but it was something. No, you passed. You passed. Wait, it was a soft pass. But here's the deal.
我忘了后来发生什么了，也许他们最终不想要我，或者诸如此类的事，但确实有那么一出。不，你拒绝了。你拒绝了。等等，那是委婉的拒绝。但情况是这样的。
I always thought it was really funny, and I thought it was, when I read that script, that's when I became a fan of yours. Hey. I can't wait for the question. So once we started to get to know each other more recently, then I did watch it,
我一直觉得它真的很好笑，而且我认为，当我读到那个剧本时，我就是在那时成了你的粉丝。嘿。我等不及那个问题了。所以自从我们最近开始更多地了解彼此之后，我确实看了，
not because I wanted to be able to, but I was like, I want to see what your deal is. How about that? Well, look, I appreciate it, Jason. Yeah, sorry, Jason. But then ultimately, you did not stick with the show clearly.
不是因为我想能够，而是我想，我得看看你到底是个什么水平。觉得怎么样？好吧，听着，我很感激，杰森。对，对不起，杰森。但最终，你显然没有继续演这个节目。
Me, on the other hand, if I were to start, I know I would go down a K-Hall of just like, Oh, this guy, Rob. Yeah. I got to eat up everything. And then I'd get stuck in the Philly, in the sunny in Philly,
另一方面，如果是我开始看的话，我知道我会掉进一个怪圈，就会想，哦，这家伙，罗布。对。我得把一切都看完。然后我就会陷在《费城永远艳阳高照》里，
and that would take me 15 years, almost literally, to watch all those episodes. I wouldn't be able to stop. I know what I'm dealing with with you. So what I do is, I keep myself in a safe little bubble of Dodgers and MSNBC,
那几乎得花掉我15年时间，字面意义上的15年，才能看完所有这些剧集。我根本停不下来。我知道我在你身上面对的是什么。所以我所做的是，我把自己保持在一个安全的道奇队和MSNBC的小泡沫里，
and I don't come out. I know what you do. I don't come out for, except for golf, and to say hello to my lovely wife and children. That's it. Rob, do you know something? So your show's on Apple, right?
而且我不会出来。我知道你是怎么做的。我除了打高尔夫，以及向我可爱的妻子和孩子们问好之外，从不出来。就这样。罗布，你知道吗？所以你的节目在Apple上，对吧？
Mythic Quest's second season is just starting. Yeah, that's correct, well, just starting. Name's Ian Grimm. Wrong. Wrong. It's Ian, you dick. And secondly. Which shows that you just Googled it,
《神话任务》第二季才刚开始。对，没错，嗯，刚开始。名字叫伊恩·格林。错。错。是伊恩，你这个混蛋。其次。这说明你刚刚用谷歌搜索了一下，
and got it wrong, because the pronunciation is iron, and that's part of the gag of the show. Yeah, that's the whole gag of the show, you dick. You know what, here's the other part. You know what, he makes himself look even worse, is that his own wife is a producer on a show that's on Apple,
还弄错了，因为正确的发音是“爱恩”，那是剧中的一个笑点。对，那是整部剧的笑点，你这个混蛋。你知道吗，还有更绝的。你知道吗，这让他看起来更糟糕的是，他自己的妻子就是Apple上一档节目的制片人，
and he hasn't watched that. I watched the first five episodes, and I continue to get a lot of heat for not finishing that up. There's a lot of content out there. Another guy that we play golf with is an ex-baseball player named Chase Utley, and I can promise you that when we play
而他居然连那个都没看。我看了前五集，而且我因为没有把它看完而一直备受指责。外面有太多的内容了。我们一起打高尔夫的另一个人是一个前棒球运动员，名叫蔡斯·阿特利，我向你保证，当我们打球时，
Jason remembers every at-bat that this man, over a 20-year period, I think he can point to an at-bat that Chase had in 2009. He's a memorable fellow. Yeah. Hey, Rob, you mentioned in the email that we ran into each other in a doctor's office once,
杰森记得这个人在20年期间的每一次打击，我想他能指出蔡斯在2009年有过的一次打击。他是个令人难忘的家伙。对。嘿，罗布，你在邮件里提到我们曾在一家诊所偶遇过一次，
how long ago was that? And what was it? Yes. Well, the reason I know that it was not memorable for you, because this was very early on in Sonny's run, there was no chance he would have ever known who I was, but I just introduced myself and said, I was a big fan of yours.
那是多久以前的事了？是什么情况？是的。好吧，我之所以知道你对这事毫无印象，因为那是《费城》刚开播的早期，他绝对不可能知道我是谁，但我当时只是自我介绍了一下，说我是你的超级粉丝。
You knew that he didn't know who you were because he tossed you his keys and said, can you give it a wash before I come back? No, I recognize, I even said in the waiting room, I said, I recognize that this is wholly inappropriate. We were at, this is full disclosure, I don't think you'll mind having me bring this up, because I know you're very open
你知道他不知道你是谁，因为他把钥匙扔给你并说：“在我回来之前能帮我洗一下吗？”不，我承认，我甚至在候诊室里就说，我承认这完全不合时宜。我们当时在，这是完全坦白，我想你不会介意我提起这个，因为我知道你对自己的
with your medical history and whatnot, but we were in a, I love it. I love talking about animals, here we go. I know you do, I saw you on Jimmy Kimmel. I'm a fan of yours. So, and I know about your other podcast that you're talking about. Thank you, thank you.
病史之类的事情非常坦诚，但我们当时在，我喜欢这样。我喜欢谈论动物，来吧。我知道你喜欢，我在吉米·吉摩尔秀上看到过你。我是你的粉丝。所以，我也知道你谈论的另一个播客。谢谢，谢谢。
Was it a dermatologist? It was, no, it was an allergist. Oh. Yes, Dr. Eiches. Dr. Eiches, oddly enough, his name is Dr. Eiches, he's the best allergist in the city of Los Angeles, and when I first moved to LA, I had terrible allergies, and I am now cured.
是个皮肤科医生吗？不是，不，是个过敏症专家。哦。是的，艾奇斯医生。艾奇斯医生，说来也怪，他叫艾奇斯医生，他是洛杉矶市最好的过敏症专家，当我刚搬到洛杉矶时，我有严重的过敏症，而我现在已经治愈了。
What were your symptoms? Seasonal, so it would just be, it would be stuffy. But you're cured, are you okay? Are you okay now with the stuff he knows? I'm concerned. We're not doing a hypochondriac to right now, okay? All right? Sean?
你的症状是什么？季节性的，所以就是，会鼻塞。但你治愈了，你没事吧？你现在对那些鼻塞没问题了吧？我很担心。我们现在不是在搞什么疑病症探讨，好吗？好吗？肖恩？
I will say, I'm cured, I have been cured. I don't know if you continue to go to Dr. Eiches, but I do not have to go anymore. Now, was this the kind of doctor where you lay on your back and he puts like a bottle of some sort of like herb or something on your chest, and he says, raise your arm, I'm gonna push down your arm, and if your arm gives a lot of resistance,
我得说，我治愈了，我已经痊愈了。我不知道你是否还在去看艾奇斯医生，但我已经不用去了。现在，这是那种让你躺在仰面躺着，然后他在你胸前放某种药瓶或草药之类的东西，并说“抬起你的手臂，我要往下压你的手臂，如果你的手臂有很多阻力，
that means you have a bad reaction to this type of herb. Have you guys ever been one of those? No man. Oh. Nobody has. No, that guy was not a doctor. Why was, and was that in a van somewhere in the valley? That was definitely somewhere in Santa Monica.
这就意味着你对这种草药有不良反应”的医生吗？你们去过那种地方吗？没有，老兄。哦。没有人去过。没有，那家伙根本不是医生。为什么，那是在山谷某个地方的厢式车里吗？那绝对是圣莫尼卡的某个地方。
I can almost promise you that. Wait, Rob, so you were, this is why I read a little bit about you having known you were coming on. And so you grew up Catholic, I grew up Catholic, which means one of us has to be gay, that's me. And your mom is now gay, lesbian, she's out. I wanna talk about that because I think that's fascinating being a child growing up.
我几乎可以向你保证。等等，罗布，所以你是，这就是为什么我在知道你要来之后读了一点关于你的资料。所以你是天主教徒长大的，我是天主教徒长大的，这意味着我们俩中必须有一个是同性恋，那个人是我。而你的母亲现在是同性恋，是女同性恋，她出柜了。我想谈谈这个，因为我觉得作为一个在成长中的孩子，这很迷人。
Like, what was the, how old were you when she came out? Did you suspect when you were younger that mom could lift heavier things than dad maybe, and now you can both play golf? Yeah, she does play golf, which is amazing, both of my mothers. So they've been, my mother left my father for her current partner, who's been my other mother
比如，她出柜时你多大？你小时候有没有怀疑过妈妈可能比爸爸能搬动更重的物体，而现在你们俩都可以一起打高尔夫了？对，她确实打高尔夫，这太惊人了，我的两个母亲都是。所以她们，我母亲为了她现在的伴侣离开了我的父亲，过去35年来，这位伴侣一直是我的另一个母亲。
for the last 35 years. I think they met, I wanna say 37 years ago, yeah. Wow, wow, wow. So they're still wonderfully happy. And in fact, even stranger, my father and his current wife are very great friends with them, and they are on vacation together right now. I love that she's his own, yes, right now.
我想她们相遇，我想说是在37年前，对。哇，哇，哇。所以她们依然非常幸福。事实上，更奇怪的是，我父亲和他的现任妻子与她们关系非常好，他们现在正一起度假。我喜欢她是他自己的，是的，就在现在。
They are in North Carolina together, run a leg. Good, and see, I just, now I'm just writing a pilot episode of a sitcom, as I'm listening, I'm just thinking, gosh, boy, this is my two moms. Remember my two dads? Oh, okay, walk us through the cold open. Yeah, no, so here we go. So, which is just a slow fade in, you know.
他们正一起在北卡罗来纳州，走过人生的一程。很好，你看，我，现在我只是在写情景喜剧的试播集，当我听着的时候，我只是在想，天哪，天哪，这是我的两个妈妈。还记得我的《两个爸爸》吗？哦，好吧，给我们过一下开场白。对，不，所以我们开始吧。所以，这只是一个缓慢的淡入，你知道的。
Okay. Uh-oh. No, I did not know that, Rob. Yes, well, you don't ask any questions about me. No, I don't, except, did you hit an eight iron? I remember one time he said to you, he said, he said, is this downwind from here? Is this usually, is there trouble on the left?
好吧。哦哦。不，我不知道这个，罗布。是的，好吧，你从来不问任何关于我的问题。不，我没有，除了，你打过8号铁吗？我记得有一次他对你说，他说，他说，这里是顺风吗？这里通常，左边有麻烦吗？
He once said to you, I remember that. No, but I really do, I really do wanna know, like, what age did she come out to you, and what was that like for you? Was it like, oh, and then what was your experience like with your peers at school, or did they know, and all that kind of stuff? Yeah, the interesting thing is that they never
他曾经对你说过，我记得那个。不，但我真的，我真的想知道，比如，她向你出柜时你多大？那对你来说是什么体验？是不是那种，哦，然后你跟学校同龄人的经历是怎样的？他们知道吗，诸如此类的事情？对，有趣的是，他们从未
actually officially came out to us. It was a much different time. This was the South Philadelphia in the early to mid 1980s, and they had three kids in a very staunch Irish Catholic neighborhood. Right, yeah. So it was a really difficult time for them, but for us, I mean, look, any divorce
真正正式向我们出柜。那是一个截然不同的时代。那是20世纪80年代初到中期的南费城，他们在一个非常坚定的爱尔兰天主教社区里有三个孩子。对，没错。所以对他们来说这是一段非常艰难的时期，但对我们来说，我是说，听着，任何离婚
is gonna be difficult on the kids, but I think it was a testament to both my father, who was in his late twenties at the time, which is incredible, and both of my mothers, who handled it with such dignity and grace, and we never really felt any acrimony or animosity between them, it was all like in support of us. However, we did recognize that mom had a roommate,
对孩子来说都是艰难的，但我认为这证明了我父亲——当时他二十多岁，这太不可思议了——以及我的两个母亲，他们以极大的尊严和优雅处理了这件事，我们从未真正感受到他们之间有任何怨恨或敌意，一切都是为了支持我们。然而，我们确实意识到妈妈有一个室友，
which isn't weird at first, because she's in her late twenties, early thirties, which of course, at the time when you're a kid, they seem like they're 50. So I have some family members that still call Scotty my roommate. Yes, yes, so mom and Mary, who's my other mother. My mom's name is Mary.
这起初并不奇怪，因为她二十多岁、三十出头，当然，当你还是个孩子的时候，他们看起来就像50岁。所以我有一些家庭成员到现在还管斯科特叫我的室友。是的，是的，所以妈妈和玛丽，那是我的另一个母亲。我妈妈叫玛丽。
Oh, there we go. Yeah, anyway, this is going great. Roommates for years, years and years and years, and nobody was really sitting us down and having a conversation with us, but as time went on, it was becoming quite evident when we would ask at 12, 13 years old, we recognized that you're roommates,
哦，原来如此。对，总之，这进展得很顺利。做室友做了多年，多年，多年，多年，没有人真正坐下来跟我们谈过话，但随着时间的推移，当我们12、13岁问起时，情况变得越来越明显，我们认识到你们是室友，
but why do you sleep in the same bed? Well, for warmth. Yeah, for warmth, it's cold. To save energy. It's not always sunny. South Philly's cold, yeah. Sean, you know, Sean, you said, you brought up the fact that, you know,
但你们为什么睡在同一张床上？嗯，为了取暖。对，为了取暖，太冷了。为了节约能源。这可不是什么阳光灿烂的日子。南费城很冷，对吧。肖恩，你知道，肖恩，你提到了，你提出了这个事实，你知道的，
that you're a Catholic and maybe that's why you're gay, and I know you were being glib, but we've never really talked about this before, because, you know, Rob, you were just saying, it was a tough time. I can't imagine how difficult that would be, and hats off to you and your whole family kind of rallying around and understanding how important that was
你是个天主教徒，也许这就是为什么你是同性恋，我知道你当时是在开玩笑，但我们以前从没真正谈论过这个，因为，你知道，罗布，你刚才说过，那是一段艰难的时期。我无法想象那会有多难，向你和你的整个家人的团结以及理解这有多么重要致敬
to kind of how difficult that must be in that time. And so, Sean, we've never really talked about this. How difficult was that growing up in your Irish Catholic existence outside of Chicago in a similar, I imagine, quite similar circumstances and knowing probably knew you were gay from... Oh yeah, five years old. Yeah, and...
那是多么艰难的一段经历。所以，肖恩，我们从来没真正谈过这个。在芝加哥郊外的爱尔兰天主教环境中长大，经历着类似，我能想象相当类似的情况，并且可能从……就知道了自己是同性恋，这有多艰难？哦，是的，五岁。对，而且……
Yeah, no, thanks for asking. It's, yeah, it was weird. You know, you go to church, you go to, you raise Irish Catholics, like you just blindly go because that's where your mom and dad and family bring you, and you learn all about, you go to CCD, I don't know if you had to go to CCD classes,
对，不，谢谢你问。这，是的，这很奇怪。你知道，你去教堂，你去，你以爱尔兰天主教徒的方式被抚养长大，就像你只是盲目地去，因为那是你爸爸妈妈和家人带你去的地方，你了解这一切，你去上CCD课程，我不知道你是否上过CCD课程，
Bible classes, and do all of that, and then you get older and you realize, oh, I can't talk about this because I'm told I'm bad. You can't talk about it at church, certainly, and Rob, were you guys religious, Rob? Did you have a difficult time with the church or your mom and your dad and all that stuff? Yes, it was just something that wasn't discussed,
圣经课程，做所有这些，然后你长大了，你意识到，哦，我不能谈论这个，因为别人告诉我我是个坏人。你当然不能在教堂里谈论它，而且罗布，你们以前信仰宗教吗，罗布？你和教堂或者你的爸爸妈妈以及所有那些事情有过艰难的时期吗？是的，这只是一个没有被讨论的话题，
but my father, we had a very close relationship with the church, because my father was almost a priest. In fact, he was in his last year of seminary school when he met my mother. So there's a whole lot of real interesting stories wrapped up in religion and sexuality and all this stuff. But there's so much guilt from what I understand from all my friends and people who are certainly Catholic,
但我父亲，我们与教堂有非常密切的关系，因为我父亲差一点成为一名神父。事实上，他遇到我母亲时正处于神学院的最后一年。所以这里面有很多关于宗教、性取向以及所有这些东西的非常有趣的故事。但据我所知，从我所有的朋友和天主教徒那里，有那么多的罪恶感，
they always talk about that Catholic guilt. There must be, for both of you guys, very complicated feelings because you're raised in the church and then you're doing something that they don't approve of. For both of you, did you feel that really in a real way? And do you still feel that today? You know, I have, I don't know about you, Rob,
他们总是谈论那种天主教式的罪恶感。对你们俩来说，一定有着非常复杂的感受，因为你们在教堂长大，然后你们在做他们不赞成的事情。对你们俩来说，你们真的有那种切身的感受吗？你们今天还能感受到吗？你知道，我有，我不知道你怎么样，罗布，
but I have anger because of the hypocrisy, because you have, by the way, well, this doesn't have to turn into religion, but growing up, it's all you hear from ads on TV and billboards in society and families and churches and everything that gay is bad, gay is bad. And then, of course, now we're in a much different place. We're still a long way to go,
但我有愤怒，因为虚伪，因为你拥有，顺便说一句，好吧，这不一定要变成宗教话题，但在成长过程中，你在电视广告、广告牌、社会、家庭、教堂以及所有地方听到的一切都是同性恋是坏事，同性恋是坏事。然后，当然，现在我们处在一个截然不同的地方。我们还有很长的路要走，
but that we're just as human as anybody else. But I got angry at the Catholic church because of the hypocrisy of thousands and thousands of children who were molested by Catholic priests. And we just kind of, well, we're not gonna talk about that. We're gonna try to bury that as much as possible. So here's all this evidence of pedophilia running amok in the Catholic church.
但我们和任何人一样都是人。但我对天主教教会感到愤怒，因为成千上万名儿童遭到天主教神父性侵的这种虚伪。而我们却只是，嗯，我们不会谈论这个。我们要尽最大可能把这事掩盖起来。所以这里有这么多的恋童癖在天主教教会里横行的证据。
And they're passing judgment on me for who I love and telling me how I should live my life. I don't know about that. And so, like they say in Shark Tank, for those reasons, I'm out. Well, let me ask the dumb, dumb question, because I am the dumb, dumb in many areas, definitely in religion.
而他们却在评判我爱谁，并告诉我应该如何生活。我不知道该怎么说。所以，就像他们在《创智赢家》里说的那样，基于这些原因，我退出了。好吧，让我问一个愚蠢得不能再愚蠢的问题，因为我在很多领域都是个笨蛋，在宗教方面绝对是。
I know you're zero. And first off, we got the quote. We got the clip. I know zero about religion. And so on this issue, is there something, and it's probably a very quick and easy answer, I apologize, but is there something in the Bible that specifically says,
我知道你完全不懂。首先，我们拿到了名言。我们拿到了片段。我对宗教一无所知。所以在这个问题上，有没有那么一条，而且这可能是一个非常快捷简单的答案，我很抱歉，但《圣经》中是不是有什么具体的话说，
you must not be with somebody of the same sex? Or is it sort of like, this is sort of an agreed upon interpretation of some of the vagaries, and it pushes it towards heterosexuality? Yes. And just like anything else in the Bible, it's a buffet where people can choose al-Aqqaar,
你绝不能和同性在一起？还是说，这有点像对某些模棱两可的内容的一种默认解释，并把它推向异性恋的方向？是的。就像《圣经》中的任何其他东西一样，它是一个自助餐，人们可以点阿尔卡尔，
which sections they want to believe and which they don't, to further reinforce their own prejudices, right? So, and we see that all day long with so many various different things. Where people will just- And people are doing that with the constitution. Of course.
他们可以选择相信哪些部分，不相信哪些部分，来进一步强化他们自己的偏见，对吧？所以，我们在很多各种不同的事情上整天都能看到这一点。人们只会——人们在对宪法做这件事。当然。
Of course. You just choose to interpret it the way that fits whatever sort of narrative you're looking for, right? And really quick, I made a glib joke about your mom, and it's just from one gay to another gay joke about playing golf and all that. So hopefully she's okay with that.
当然。你只是选择按照符合你正在寻找的某种叙事的方式去解释它，对吧？顺便快说一句，我刚刚对你妈妈开了一个轻率的玩笑，那只是从一个同性恋到另一个同性恋关于打高尔夫球之类事情的玩笑。所以希望她不会介意这个。
My mother could give two flying fucks what anybody says about her, that's for sure. But that's having grown up in South Philly. Well, I wanted you to apologize to me for making fun of me for playing golf too, just in general. But not to show you, to demonstrate how difficult this is for people. And again, that's why I have endless compassion
我母亲才不在乎任何人对她评头论足呢，那是绝对的。但那是在南费城长大的人的特质。好吧，我还想让你为取笑我打高尔夫球向我道歉呢，就当是总体上而言。但为了向你展示这对人们来说有多么困难。再说一次，这就是为什么我有无尽的同情心
and empathy, certainly for my mother who was navigating this in the mid 1980s. But we grew up essentially in the gay community, at least half 50% of the time we were in the gay community. And yet I have two gay brothers, one of whom did not come out to me till he was in his 20s. Wow. Which is just fascinating because he still felt
和同理心，当然是对在20世纪80年代中期摸索这一切的我的母亲。但我们基本上是在同性恋社区中长大的，至少有一半，50%的时间我们在同性恋社区中。然而我有两个同性恋哥哥，其中一个直到二十多岁才向我出柜。哇。这太迷人了，因为他仍然觉得
from a cultural and societal perspective that he just didn't feel comfortable even telling his own brother. Right, there's... Did he tell your mom earlier? No. No. Wow. Growing up in a culture in the family
从文化和社会的角度来看，他甚至觉得跟自己的亲兄弟说出口都觉得不自在。对，有……他早点告诉你的妈妈了吗？没有。没有。哇。在一个文化和家庭中长大，
where it was not only in existence, but it was embraced and it was, well, I don't know if comfortable, but that's, wow. Did he explain why he still felt so kind of uncomfortable until 20, something that come out? He did. And I mean, look, to bring it back full circle
那里不仅存在这种现象，而且被接受，并且，嗯，我不知道算不算舒适，但那是，哇。他解释过为什么直到二十多岁才感觉这么不自在而出柜吗？他解释了。我的意思是，听着，为了绕回起点
and not to, I know that this show is not, it's sort of anathema to be sincere. And yes, to be sincere. That's Will's fault. You gotta be careful about being sincere cause you'll get hurt real bad. Right, well, I'm gonna point, I'm gonna shine the light in Sean's direction.
而不是，我知道这个节目不是，表现得真诚在这里似乎有些格格不入。是的，要真诚。那是威尔的错。你得小心表现得真诚，因为你会受很重的伤。好吧，我要把聚光灯，我要把聚光灯照向肖恩的方向。
So what I said to Sean in the doctor's office at Dr. Eiches was that I believe that Will and Grace, not single-handedly, but was a massive, massive part of a cultural revolution that obviously started in the 60s in Sevedes and Stonewall, which was the beginning of it. But I think like really changing hearts and minds,
所以我当时在艾奇斯医生的诊所对肖恩说的是，我相信《威尔与格蕾丝》，虽然不是一己之力，但它是60年代和70年代以及石墙事件中显然开始的文化革命的巨大、巨大的一部分，那是这场革命的开端。但我认为，真正改变人心，
which I know you've discussed ad nauseam, Sean, but I just wanna bring it back to that for a second. That show was seminal. Seminal for so many people. And as a straight white dude who spent his entire life around other straight white dudes to see how impactful that show was, was really changed people's lives.
我知道你们已经对此讨论过无数次了，肖恩，但我只是想把话题重新引回那上面一会儿。那个节目具有开创性。对很多人来说具有开创性。作为一个一辈子都和直男混在一起的直男白人，看到那个节目产生了多大的影响力，真的改变了人们的生活。
I mean, it really did. And I think that there's not a, it's not a coincidence that people like my brother and then my second brother, who's significantly younger than me, 14 years younger than me, was never in the closet. So my youngest brother, who's four years younger than me, didn't come out to me till he was in his 20s.
我是说，真的改变了。而且我认为，这并非巧合，像我哥哥，然后是我的第二个弟弟——他比我小得多，比我小14岁——就从来没有进过衣柜。所以我的最小的弟弟，他比我小四岁，直到二十多岁才向我出柜。
And then my youngest brother was just always out. And I think that shows that there was just a dramatic shift in the late 90s, early 2000s, and it continues today and in how accepted that this is a part of our culture. And these are our fellow humans. Very, very kind of you to say. Sean, how good does that fucking feel to hear that from Rob?
然后我最小的弟弟就一直是出柜状态。我认为这表明，在90年代末、2000年代初，发生了一次巨大的转变，而且这种转变一直延续到今天，人们如何接受这是我们文化的一部分。而这些都是我们的同胞。你这么说真是太好了，太善良了。肖恩，听到罗布这么说，你心里感觉有多爽？
I mean, how? Unbelievable. You know, it's very, very sweet. We always say that's the power of comedy. You can achieve so many things with the power of comedy and educate people without them knowing it, you know, because you bring them along and you bring them in. But, you know, I remember the show Donahue
我是说，有多爽？难以置信。你知道，这非常非常甜蜜。我们总是说，这就是喜剧的力量。你可以通过喜剧的力量实现许多目标，在人们不知不觉中教育他们，你知道的，因为你带着他们一起走，把他们拉进来。但是，你知道，我记得《唐纳休》这个节目
back in the 70s and 80s, right? Where he's like, today we have on Congress person this and we have a gay person on. And that was, that was the subject that there just was a gay person on the TV. What's it like being, and now it's like, yeah, what a surprise that we're all normal. We're all just like you.
在70年代和80年代的时候，对吧？当时他的节目是，今天我们请到了某某国会议员，我们还请了一位同性恋者。而这就是，当时的主题仅仅是电视上出现了一个同性恋者。那种感觉是什么样的，而现在就像是，是的，我们都很正常，这有什么好惊讶的。我们都和你一样。
It's like newsflash. We're all human and we're all part of the human race. No, but it's funny. I was just thinking that like, how important, first of all, how amazing that must feel knowing that you've helped in whatever way, you know, and it's never enough as you know, it'll never be enough.
这就像是突发新闻。我们都是人类，我们都是人类大家庭的一部分。不，但这很有趣。我刚才在想，首先，知道自己在某种程度上提供了帮助，这种感觉一定有多棒，你知道的，而且正如你所知，这永远不够，这永远不会够。
There'll be critics who all- Long way to go. Yeah, but you did this or you did that, like fuck it. Who, you know, you can't please everybody all the time. But the fact that you're able to, that Rob's able to say that and really mean that must feel amazing, the fact that I realized when asking you about your upbringing that way,
总会有批评者说——还有很长的路要走。对，但你做了这个或者你做了那个，去他妈的。谁，你知道的，你不可能永远取悦所有人。但你能够做到这一点，罗布能够说出那样的话并且是发自内心的，这一定感觉太棒了，当我以那种方式问起你的成长经历时我意识到，
that you and I have been friends for almost 20 years, and we've never really talked about that aspect of it. But isn't that such a win? I guess so. That we've never talked about it, that it's normal. Yeah, I guess, right? And other people would say, well, you're insensitive for not having asked,
你和我已经是将近20年的朋友了，而我们从未真正谈论过那方面的 ASPECT。但这难道不是一场巨大的胜利吗？我想是的吧。我们从未谈论过它，这说明它是正常的。对，我想是吧，对吧？其他人可能会说，你没有问这个真是太不体贴了，
but I never knew, do you ever feel that way? No, never ever. I mean, we're good friends. Yeah, yeah, exactly. But that's because you guys are evolved and educated and normal and all of those things. And the other thing to bring it back, really full circle is Rob, I don't know if you,
但我从来不知道，你曾经有过那种感觉吗？不，从来没有。我是说，我们是好朋友。对，对，没错。但那是因为你们思想成熟、受过教育、正常，具备所有这些东西。还有一件事，为了真正把话题完美收官，罗布，我不知道你是不是，
Sean told you, you know why he was out the allergist? He's, because he was allergic to laughs. Yeah. Did you know that? Yeah. No, just to wrap that up, Rob, thank you for saying that's very nice. The show is just bigger than all of us,
肖恩跟你说过吗，你知道他为什么去看过敏症专家吗？他，因为他对笑声过敏。对。你知道吗？没有，只是为了总结一下，罗布，谢谢你这么说，这非常暖心。这个节目比我们所有人都大，
and I was just happy to get a job. And then it became this byproduct that we did all of this for to educate America without them knowing is what I was saying. And now you live in a mansion and you're totally disconnected from the rest of the world. I'm very grateful for you saying that. We get it.
我当时只是很高兴能得到一份工作。然后它变成了一种副产品，我们在不知不觉中做这一切来教育美国人，这就是我想说的。而现在你住在大豪宅里，完全与世隔绝了。我很感激你能这么说。我们懂的。
We're doing a lot. And you saying that actually helps even more people. And we got a long way to go. And I'm so glad that you are educated. I want to say I'm very, I loved seeing this exchange just to wrap my own wrap up. I love it so much. I love Sean so much.
我们做出了很多贡献。而你这么说实际上能帮助更多的人。我们还有很长的路要走。我很高兴你受过良好的教育。我想说我非常，我很高兴看到这次交流，为了给我的部分做个收尾。我太喜欢这个了。我太喜欢肖恩了。
I love you guys too very, very much. And it's just, that was just. Thank you, Will. Yeah. It's just made my day. Okay. And I, you know what for, I would say this, sorry. I say this to you guys all the time,
我也非常非常喜欢你们。这真的是。谢谢你，威尔。对。这让我的一整天都过得很美好。好吧。而且我，你知道为了，我想这么说，抱歉。我总是对你们这么说，
to be the unknown acceptance of a gay guy by straight men is a big deal. Because it's in, we grew up in our DNA to just believe that, oh, all straight guys have a problem with gay guys, you know? And so, and we're always walking around with the added layer of, will they accept me for who I am instead of, you know, anything else?
作为一个同性恋者能够得到直男无条件的接受，这是一件大事。因为在我们成长过程中的基因里，就是去相信，哦，所有的直男都对同性恋有意见，你知道吗？所以，我们总是随身带着一层额外的负担，他们会因为我是谁而接受我，而不是因为其他任何事情吗？
And of course, we still have to educate people. There's people that don't live in Los Angeles and New York where you can just, you know, there's lots of cultures happening all around everybody. So it's easier to accept. But we have to do a lot of work still to make sure people know, to see us as human. Rob, what's the shooting schedule like
当然，我们仍然必须教育人们。有些人并不住在洛杉矶和纽约，在那里你可以，你知道的，周围每个人都在发生着各种各样的文化交流。所以更容易接受。但我们仍然必须做很多工作，确保人们知道，把我们当作人类来看待。罗布，拍摄日程是怎样的，
that all of a sudden he filled out? Listener, Will has decided to use our time for his lunch time. And so he keeps moving the mic away so he can get a little fatter. Fucking Bateman, he spends most of his time eating and he'll go like this. He'll ask questions to people with his mouth full.
以至于他突然间变得这么丰满？听众们，威尔决定把我们的时间用作他的午餐时间。所以他不断把麦克风移开，这样他就能吃得更胖一点。他妈的贝特曼，他大部分时间都在吃东西，他会像这样。他会满嘴食物地问别人问题。
Do you find it hard? I'm like, what the fuck? No, I don't. You do all the time. Don't. Shut up. What I find so fascinating about Jason is that you never really know
你觉得这很难吗？我心想，这他妈叫什么事？不，我不觉得。你一直都这样。别这样。闭嘴。我对杰森最着迷的地方在于，你永远不知道
whether he's actually getting hot or not. So he's joking and you're laughing and you're laughing and you're laughing and then you look over and he's looking at you and you realize, oh, there's been a transition. And I didn't notice the transition. Now he's actually angry. And there's no difference between Jason being funny
他到底是真生气还是假生气。所以他开玩笑，然后你笑，你笑，你笑，接着你看过去，发现他正看着你，然后你意识到，哦，发生转变了。而我却没有注意到这个转变。现在他真的生气了。而且杰森搞笑和
and Jason being angry. And both of them are terrifying because you could be eviscerated from the knave to the chop. Well, Sean, I don't know if you've ever really seen me angry, have you? Will, I think you've seen me angry. Is it, there's not, I don't,
杰森生气之间没有什么区别。这两者都极其可怕，因为你可能会被从头到脚开膛破肚。好吧，肖恩，我不知道你是否真的见过我生气，对吧？威尔，我想你见过我生气。是不是，没有，我不知道，
you can tell if I'm really pissed, can't you? No, I think Rob's onto something here. I think that's a really good point. I think that Rob first noticed it on the golf course that you had a blow-up hole and Jason went kind of crazy for a second. No, crazy means quiet, I think, right? Ooh.
你能看出我是不是真的气炸了，对吧？不，我觉得罗布在这点上说得对。我觉得这是一个非常好的观点。我觉得罗布最初是在高尔夫球场上注意到这一点的，你有一个洞打砸了，然后杰森疯狂了一小会儿。不，疯狂意味着安静，我想，对吧？噢。
A little nasty. Now that I'm getting older and the elasticity's leaving my face. So now my brow's just hanging over my eyeballs a little bit and I look constantly peeved. Do you wish you had, cause look at Rob. Rob looks so great.
有点讨厌。既然我老了，脸上的弹性也在消失。所以现在我的眉毛稍微压在眼珠上面一点，我看起来总是很不高兴。你希望自己能……因为你看罗布。罗布看起来太棒了。
We opened with that. Look at Jesus. He was just on the cover of Men's Health Magazine, which they must have lost my number because I did change numbers a while. I don't know what, anyway, the point is they went with Rob. Yeah, this month, yeah.
我们一开始就谈了这个。看耶稣。他刚登上《男士健康》杂志的封面，他们肯定弄丢了我的电话号码，因为我确实换过一段时间号码。我不知道，总之，重点是他们选了罗布。对，这个月，对。
He looks incredible. I know you get a lot of shit from your friends for it, but. I heard the story about you yo-yo-ing. You're weight yo-yo-ing for the shoot or something. Oh, look, you do a show for 14 years coming up on 15. You gotta try and find new ways to get Jason to watch. I'm waiting for you guys to get a few episodes so I can really binge it.
他看起来帅呆了。我知道你的朋友们为此没少挖苦你，不过。我听说了你体重反弹的事。你为了拍摄控制体重或者别的什么。哦，听着，一部剧拍了14年，马上要进第15年了。你得想办法让杰森看。我等着你们攒够几集，这样我就可以一口气看个痛快了。
I'm gonna send you a couple of things. Don't, cause then I'll be nervous around you. I like that we have a comfortable relationship. Think about how rude it is, cause both you and Charlie are on Sunny and he's friends with Charlie too and he's done a couple movies with Charlie. Yeah, yeah.
我要给你发几段。别发，不然我在你面前会紧张的。我喜欢我们之间这种轻松的关系。想想看这有多粗鲁，因为你和查理都在拍《费城永远阳光灿烂》，而且他和查理也是朋友，他还和查理拍过几部电影。对，对。
And he still hasn't watched. Listen, the few times I've been given a chance to direct, I've hired people that I've never seen act before, but I just get a sense that they're, yeah, but I just, it doesn't matter to me. Like if you, you know, you're. Right for the part, you're right for the part, right.
而他到现在还没看。听着，我有几次得到执导机会时，我雇过那些我从未看过他们演戏的人，但我就是有一种感觉，他们……是的，但我就是，这对我来说不重要。就像如果你，你知道的，你
You're a real loose cannon, you know that's what I'm saying? I can't understand what you're saying. Put the food down. God. It's all, you always have food in your hands. Okay, so wait, listen, Rob. I almost barf, I almost made me barf. I want to get to this.
适合这个角色，你就是适合这个角色，对吧。你真是个不受约束的家伙，你知道我这是什么意思吗？我听不懂你在说什么。把食物放下。天哪。这全，你手里总是拿着食物。好吧，等等，听着，罗布。
It's always sending food to the left because it's a great story. You shot a pilot with Charlie Day and Glenn Howerton for $200, is that true? And was it on your iPhone? And the reason I think this is fascinating is because my sister tracing Wisconsin, she gets approached a lot by some friends who have kids
我差点吐了，我差点被弄得想吐。我想谈谈这个。一直在把食物推到左边，因为这是个好故事。你和查理·戴、格伦·霍顿花了200美元拍了一部试播集，这是真的吗？而且是用你的iPhone拍的吗？我之所以觉得这很迷人，是因为我在威斯康星州的姐姐崔西，经常有一些有孩子的朋
who always kind of want to ask advice about how to break into showbiz, right? So in turn, I get asked to answer that question on her behalf and I always get the same advice as to what you accomplish, which is pick up a camera or your phone and just start fucking making stuff and shooting stuff and make sure it's great.
友来找她，他们总是想打听怎么才能进入演艺圈，对吧？所以反过来，我会被要求代她回答这个问题，而我得到的建议总是和你所做成的事情一样，那就是拿起摄像机或手机，开始他妈的创作和拍摄，并确保它很棒。
Well, that's a good question. But hang on, before Rob answers that, your sister Tracy gets asked by people in the street how to break into showbiz and yet we have to stop the show all the time to explain to her showbiz term. Why the fuck are they asking her? No, she has friends with kids who are like,
嗯，这是个好问题。但是等等，在罗布回答之前，你姐姐崔西在街上被人问到怎么进入演艺圈，然而我们却不得不经常停下节目来向她解释演艺圈的术语。为什么他妈的他们要问她？不，她有一些朋友带着孩子，他们会问，
hey, can you ask your brother what their advice for them? And you're the perfect example of what that is, Rob, which is like, you took 200 bucks and you shot a pilot, is that true? It is, but you asked if we shot it on iPhones and the show is so old that it is well before iPhones. Smartphones didn't even exist. So this would have been 2004.
嘿，你能问问你弟弟他们有什么建议吗？而你就是那种情况的完美例子，罗布，那就是，你花了200块钱拍了一部试播集，这是真的吗？是的，但你问我们是不是用iPhone拍的，这部剧太老了，那远在iPhone出现之前。智能手机甚至都还不存在。所以这应该是在2004年。
And I just went to Best Buy and I was working at a restaurant at the time and I took out a credit card and I just bought a camera. And then we just learned how to edit on our MacBooks and thankfully those did exist. That's amazing. But if, listener, don't manage your expectations. You guys are going into your 15th year
我当时去了百思买，我当时在一家餐馆打工，我刷了信用卡，买了一台摄像机。然后我们就学会了在MacBook上剪辑，谢天谢地，那些东西确实存在。这太了不起了。但是，听众朋友们，不要抱太大期望。你们即将迈入第15个年头，
on something you shot on a slow Wednesday, you went into a Best Buy and said, I'm gonna buy a home video camera and take my fucking shot at the business tree. And you guys, I don't even want to start, you just bought a soccer team. So I just, God bless everybody with dreams and please pursue them.
拍的是你们在一个慵懒的周三拍的东西，你走进一家百思买，说我要买一台家用摄像机，在娱乐圈碰碰我他妈的运气。而你们，我甚至都不想开始，你们刚刚买下了一支足球队。所以我只能说，上帝保佑所有有梦想的人，请去追求它们吧。
But hold on to that restaurant job Rob had when he shot it because that gives you that, what is it Will, sexy indifference? Sexy indifference? Because you got a day job, you know? I don't believe that you wish everybody well with their dreams either. I wish them well, but I am the first one to say,
不过，请记住罗布拍片时做的那份餐馆工作，因为这能带给你那种，是什么来着，威尔，性感冷漠？性感冷漠？因为你有一份日常工作，你知道吗？我才不信你也祝愿每个人的梦想都能成真呢。我祝愿他们成功，但我也是第一个说，
there's something to be said for those that don't need it and or those that don't, you know, people say, well, you know, the people that succeed or the people that can't live without it, the passion, I disagree. I think you have to have a little bit of indifference there. It's just like, it's like high school, right? Going after the guy or the girl.
对于那些不需要它的人和/或者那些不需要的人来说，确实有话可说，你知道的，人们会说，嗯，你知道，成功的人是那些没有它就活不下去的人，那种激情，我不同意。我认为你必须在其中带有一点冷漠。这就像，这就像高中，对吧？追求那个男生或女生。
If you're kind of, you know, not playing hard to get like manipulating, but if you kind of take it or leave it, it's very attractive. So make sure there's something in your life that keeps it. Okay. Well, I mean, it sounds like kind of great advice and also kind of terrible advice.
如果你有点，你知道的，不是欲擒故纵那种操纵，而是那种可有可无的态度，这非常具有吸引力。所以，确保你的生活中有些东西能保持这种状态。好吧。我的意思是，这听起来既是个很棒的建议，同时也是个挺糟糕的建议。
Rob, so you make the pilot, you make the pilot for 200 bucks, you go into Best Buy, you buy this thing, you shoot the pilot, then what? Like how millions of people have shot shit? We realized it wasn't good enough. So we shot it again. Then we realized it wasn't good enough.
罗布，所以你制作了试播集，你花了200块钱制作了试播集，你走进百思买，你买了这玩意儿，你拍了试播集，然后呢？就像几百万人拍过的那种破玩意儿？我们意识到它不够好。所以我们又拍了一遍。然后我们意识到它还是不够好。
So we shot it again and we would just keep shooting it whenever people were available in our various apartments. We had different iterations of at one point, I had a different person playing the character that I wound up playing, who then moved on to being a different character in the show. And he didn't, he wasn't able to reshoot it
所以我们又拍了一遍，只要大家在各自的公寓里有空，我们就会一直拍下去。我们有过不同的版本，有一段时间，我让另一个人扮演我最终扮演的角色，后来他变成了剧中的另一个角色。而他没能重新拍摄
for the third time because his girlfriend was in town. It was like, it was just, we were never thinking we were making a TV show. We were just trying to make something fun and something good. And we just kept iterating because it wasn't good enough. And then finally we thought it was good enough. And then we thought, well, this could be a TV show, but I thought if we're gonna actually try and sell it,
第三次，因为他女朋友当时在城里。这就像是，我们从来没想过我们在拍一部电视剧。我们只是想做一些有趣和优秀的东西。我们不断迭代，因为还不够好。然后最后我们觉得够好了。接着我们想，嗯，这可以成为一部电视剧，但我想如果我们真的要试着把它卖掉，
we should make a second one so that we can prove that, you know, a waiter can be a show runner. I think it was 25 or 26 at the time. And so we wanted to make a second one to basically have this like package that we could then take around town. And that's what we did.
我们应该再拍第二部，这样我们就能证明，你知道的，一个服务生可以当运作人。我当时大概25或26岁。所以我们想拍第二部，基本上是为了做成这样一个套餐，然后我们可以把它带到城里到处推销。这就是我们所做的。
And then did you, did you walk it in or did you send it in or how did that work? No, I didn't trust people enough to send it in. I didn't think anybody would go to, would actually watch it. So we went in and I'll tell you, this is how long ago it was. Even though DVDs did exist, of course, at the time, they were, when you burned them off of Max,
然后，你是，你是亲自送去还是寄过去的，或者那是怎么运作的？不，我不信任别人，所以没有寄过去。我觉得不会有人去，真的会看。所以我们亲自去了，我告诉你，这已经是多久以前的事了。尽管当时DVD当然已经存在了，但是，当你从Mac上刻录它们时，
they just, you couldn't count on them, they're unreliable. So we had to transfer it onto a VHS tape. So I had a VHS tape, which we would take around, over two days, I took it to, I don't know, seven networks. And then we had offers from all of them, except one, Fox, right, Fox. Fox just didn't get it. Big Fox, big Fox.
它们就是，你根本指望不上，它们很不稳定。所以我们不得不把它转存到VHS录像带上。所以我有一盘VHS录像带，我们带着它，在两天时间里，我把它带到了，我不知道，大约七家电视台。然后我们收到了他们所有人的报价，除了一个，福克斯，对吧，福克斯。福克斯就是没看懂。大福克斯，大福克斯。
Just big Fox just didn't get it at all at the time. They're all, those people have blown gone, but. Well, you can name them here if you want to shame them. I definitely remember who they are. Sure. And that's just the part of the chip on my shoulder. They say it was, and we'll cut it, I promise. We promise.
只有大福克斯当时根本没看懂。那些人都已经卷铺盖走人了，不过。好吧，如果你想羞辱他们，你可以在这里点名。我绝对记得他们是谁。当然。这也是我心结的一部分。他们说那是，我们会剪掉的，我保证。我们保证。
I bet you still got the tape, right? You must still have it. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. That's so cool. I still have the tape. Now, you know, they will de-generate really quickly, those VHS tapes. You have it like in a little box.
我敢打赌你还留着那盘带子，对吧？你一定还留着。哦，太棒了，是的，是的，是的。太酷了。我甚至还留着那盘带子。现在，你知道的，它们会退化得非常快，那些VHS录像带。你把它放在一个小盒子里吗？
We've already transferred it. We've already transferred it digitally, yes. And now people are approaching us about NFTs, and now I understand what an NFT is. I'm sure people of your generation do not. All right, I'm too young. I'm too young. No, Jason, why don't you explain it to me,
我们已经转换过了。我们已经把它数字化转换了，是的。现在人们开始向我们询问NFT，现在我终于明白什么是NFT了。我敢肯定你们这代人不知道。好吧，我太年轻了。我太年轻了。不，杰森，你为什么不给我解释一下，
because he doesn't know what it is. I know exactly what it is. I'm gonna be listening, but I want you to address well. By the way, NFTs are a carbon disaster. They're completely gonna ruin this planet, so I won't buy NFTs. Well, as I've had it explained to me over the course of the last few weeks, that is,
因为他不知道那是什么。我完全知道那是什么。我会听着的，但我希望你向威尔解释。顺便说一句，NFT是一场碳灾难。它们会彻底毁了这个星球，所以我不会买NFT。好吧，正如过去几周别人向我解释的那样，那是，
well, look, there's always gonna be people who claim that they are not destroying the environment for the sake of commerce, and maybe they quite possibly are. However, Rob, please explain what an NFT is. Oh, it's gonna be so boring, and it's gonna be impossible to...
好吧，听着，总会有人声称他们没有为了商业利益而破坏环境，也许他们确实在破坏。然而，罗布，请解释一下什么是NFT。哦，这会超级无聊，而且很难……
Well, make it exciting. A non-fungible token. Everybody knows what that is. Okay, it's called a non-fungible token. And again, I'm going to explain it as best it was explained to me in the simplest terms. You know what, explain it like you're explaining it to Bateman.
好吧，把它说得刺激一点。非同质化代币。每个人都知道那是什么。好吧，它叫非同质化代币。再次说明，我将用最简单的术语，按照别人向我解释的方式来解释它。你知道吗，就像你向巴特曼解释那样来解释它。
That's what I always do. Just do it like that. So, listener, what Will just said is explain it like you're explaining it to Bateman. That's right. God. Okay, so an NFT... It's like a moving image you can buy.
我一直都是这么做的。照那样做就行了。所以，听众朋友们，威尔刚才说的是像向巴特曼解释一样来解释它。没错。天哪。好吧，所以NFT……这就像一个你可以买的动态图像。
It's a non-fungible... Yes, it's essentially a piece of digital art. We'll call it a piece of digital art. And it exists in something called the blockchain. The blockchain, so it's in the ether, right? So, the blockchain is what certifies this piece of art as being an original. So, for example, you could literally...
它是一个非同质化……是的，它本质上一件数字艺术品。我们称之为一件数字艺术品。它存在于一个叫区块链的东西里。区块链，所以它在虚空中，对吧？所以，区块链是证明这件艺术品为原创的东西。例如，你完全可以……
Patrick Mahomes did this. He designed a football helmet, a 3D football helmet in a digital space. And he is the artist of that digital art. And then he sold that to somebody for a massive amount of money. We could look it up and do a fact check on it, but I think it was a couple million bucks.
帕特里克·马霍姆斯就这么做了。他在数字空间设计了一个橄榄球头盔，一个3D橄榄球头盔。他是那个数字艺术品的艺术家。然后他以巨额资金把它卖给了一个人。我们可以查一下并核实一下，但我认为是几百万美元。
So, the first question that comes up is, well, why is that worth anything? Because you could just make a digital copy. I'm sending gifts back and forth all day long. It's the same theory that say a Picasso hanging on your wall is actually not worth technically anything if you break it down to its most basic parts, which is just paint and canvas.
所以，出现滴第一个问题是，为什么这玩意儿有价值？因为你完全可以做一个数字副本。我整天都在发GIF动图。这和挂在你墙上的毕加索其实并没有什么技术上的价值是同一个理论，如果你把它分解成最基本的组成部分，那不过是颜料和画布。
It's the value that we put on it. And the reason it's valuable is because it's one of a kind. You can make a print of a Picasso, and that can be a poster somewhere, but that costs $4, whereas the Picasso costs $40 million. Rob, I would love to see you... Well, just for their faces,
这是我们赋予它的价值。它之所以有价值，是因为它是独一无二的。你可以印一张毕加索的复制品，那可以是一张某处的招贴画，只要4美元，而毕加索则要4000万美元。罗布，我很想看你……好吧，就看他们的表情，
just to see how broken these two faces would be, you explaining blockchain. Just because you'd lose them, sentence one. And then I want to get into Bitcoin and the one... What's the other one? Dogecoin. Just believe me, I'm definitely not the person that should be explaining this.
只要看看这两个人听到你解释区块链时表情会有多崩溃。就因为你从第一句话就会把他们彻底搞懵。然后我想聊聊比特币和那个……另一个是什么？狗狗币。相信我，我绝对不是该解释这个的人。
You should be bringing on somebody way smarter. Oh, that's all right. I just like money. I like money, and I like making money. So when people come to me and say, we have a way for you to make money, I say, tell me more. And then they explain it to me in caveman.
你应该请一个聪明得多的人来。哦，没关系。我只是喜欢钱。我喜欢钱，我喜欢赚钱。所以当人们来找我，说我们有个办法让你赚钱时，我会说，多告诉我点。然后他们用山顶洞人的语言向我解释。
That seems like good business acumen. Wait, so you bought the football team list because we have brought it up a couple of times. Let's talk about the football team that you bought in Wales. Yes. With Brian Reynolds. You and Brian Reynolds bought it. I'm so happy that you called him Brian.
这听起来很有商业头脑。等等，所以你买下了那支足球队，听众朋友们，因为我们已经提了好几次了。我们来聊聊你在威尔士买的那支足球队吧。是的。和瑞安·雷诺兹一起。你和瑞安·雷诺兹买的。我真高兴你叫他布莱恩。
Every chance, I don't know him that well, but every time I see him, I always call him Brian. There's a little Brian Reynolds. I don't think he does love it, or he does. I doubt he does. No, sorry, take another bite. We'll keep talking, go ahead. Fuck.
每次有机会，我其实没那么了解他，但每次我见到他，我都叫他布莱恩。有个小小的布莱恩·雷诺兹。我不觉得他会喜欢，或者他喜欢。我怀疑他不会。不，抱歉，再咬一口。我们继续聊，说吧。操。
I bought a football team in Wales with Brian, and so Ryan and I bought a football team in Wales and we're making a documentary about the process. Nice. It's going to be on FX on Hulu, and then I believe internationally it's going to be on Disney Plus. It's going to come out sometime in 2022, and it's going to be on for at least two seasons.
我和布莱恩在威尔士买了一支足球队，我和瑞安在威尔士买了一支足球队，我们正在拍摄一部关于这个过程的纪录片。太棒了。它将在FX的Hulu上播出，然后我相信国际上它将在Disney Plus上播出。它将在2022年的某个时候上映，并且至少会播出两季。
Here we go. Yes, I'll narrate it. Wow, that's great. There we go. That's really, really cool. So, but what is the name of the team? The name of the team is Wrexham Red Dragons. They are in Wrexham, which is in which is in North Wales,
来吧。是的，我会担任旁白。哇，太棒了。这就对了。这真的，真的很酷。所以，但是这支球队叫什么名字？这支球队的名字叫雷克萨姆红龙。他们在雷克萨姆，雷克萨姆在，在北威尔士，
but they play in the English football system. And the thing about the English football system, which I don't know if you guys know anything about soccer and or football, I certainly did not. A fair bet. I know a fair bet. I mean, I was watching this morning, yeah. Yeah. So at the start of lockdown, I really truly didn't know much about it,
但他们在英格兰足球体系中踢球。关于英格兰足球体系，我不知道你们对英格兰足球和/或足球了解多少，我肯定是不了解的。十拿九稳。我十拿九稳。我是说，我今天早上还在看，对。对。所以在封锁开始时，我真的对它知之甚少，
but the idea of being relegated and and promoted was something that was new to me. So if you play in one of the leagues, everybody's heard of the Premier League, I think. That's where that's where all the Liverpool and Arsenal and Chelsea, all the biggest teams in the world play. And for some understanding of scale for Americans, it's obviously the big it's the biggest sport in the world.
但降级和升级的概念对我来说是个新鲜事。如果你在其中一个联赛踢球，我想每个人都听说过英超联赛。那是，那是利物浦、阿森纳、切尔西，世界上所有最大牌的球队踢球的地方。为了让美国人对规模有个概念，显然它是世界上最大，最大的体育运动。
And and some of these teams are worth billions and billions and billions of dollars. Some of these players get paid 50, 60 million dollars a year. So they sort of dwarf a lot of American sports. But the idea of being promoted and then relegated is when you start and say that you're in the Premier League, which is the top league. If you become coming last that season,
而且其中一些球队价值数十亿、数十亿、数十亿美元。其中一些球员一年拿5000万、6000万美元的薪水。所以它们让许多美国体育运动相形见绌。但升降级的概念是，当你开始时，假设你在英超联赛，那是顶级联赛。如果你那个赛季垫底，
you get kicked out of the league and you get kicked down. Bottom three teams get relegated to the level below them. Now, what that can actually start is a free fall. So you can have a team that's worth a couple of billion dollars that free falls down into the league below them. And then if they lose that, they get kicked out of the league below that. So you can find Sunderland. Yes, exactly. Sunderland is a club that is that is a historic club
你就会被踢出联赛，往下掉。倒数三支球队会降级到他们之下的级别。现在，这实际上可能引发一场自由落体。所以你可能会拥有一支价值几十亿美元的球队，结果自由落体掉到他们之下的联赛。然后如果他们输了，他们就会被踢出再下一级的联赛。所以你可以找到桑德兰。对，没错。桑德兰是一家历史悠久的俱乐部，
and and used to be in the Premier League. And now they're down into League One and not doing so well, which is three leagues below the Premier League. Anyway, the point is that if you can get relegated, you can also get promoted, meaning you could take a really low level team. So we found a team in the fifth tier and and they are not. Um, it's actually the third oldest club in the world, and they play in the oldest international football stadium in the world.
过去曾在英超联赛踢球。现在他们掉到了英甲联赛，表现也不是很好，那是英超联赛底下的第三个级别。总之，重点是如果你能降级，你也能升级，这意味着你可以带一支非常低等级的球队。所以我们在第五级联赛找到了一支球队，他们不是。嗯，这实际上是世界上第三古老的俱乐部，他们在世界上最古老的国际足球场踢球。
But they've fallen on hard times in the last really last 20 years and they've been sort of out of the league. But we are our goal is to get them back up into the league and get them promoted and and you go up a division, hopefully every few years until you can reach the pinnacle again. And what is it? What is it? Obviously, if they're winning tons of games, that happens. But what's the clear thing that you can do to help them win games?
但他们在过去，确切地说是过去20年里遭遇了不顺，有点脱离了联赛。但我们的目标是让他们重回联赛，让他们升级，每隔几年提升一个级别，直到你再次登上巅峰。这是什么？这是什么？显然，如果他们赢了很多比赛，就会发生这种情况。但你能做些什么来明确帮助他们赢得比赛？
Is it is it as clean as just spending a bunch of money to buy great players? Yeah. So that's a huge part of it. Obviously, it's just like infusing it with with capital right off right off the bat. But one of the core principles that we've that we've put out there that's like really important to us is that you notice just like anything else that if the community, the fan base, the support is behind the club, it fuels the club in so many different ways. So it's not just about us writing a check,
是，是不是只要花一大笔钱买优秀的球员那么简单？是的。所以这是其中很大一部分。显然，这就好比直接注入资金。但我们提出的核心原则之一，对我们来说非常重要，那就是你会注意到，和其他任何事情一样，如果社区、球迷基础、支持力量支持这家俱乐部，它就会以各种不同的方式为俱乐部注入动力。所以这不仅仅是我们开一张支票，
but it's also about getting the town, getting the region of North Wales and then and then growing the exposure of a global, hopefully a global audience of global supporters, which then can start creating a self sufficient club. And so we're not just writing checks. Have you spent time in Wales, Rob? Yeah, I've never been not yet. I have. Listen, I'm beloved in Wales. Oh, he's pitching himself as a mascot.
而且还要让这个小镇、北威尔士地区参与进来，并扩大全球曝光度，希望培养全球观众和全球支持者，这样就能开始打造一家自给自足的俱乐部。所以我们不只是在开支票。你在威尔士待过吗，罗布？是的，我从没去过，还没有。我去过。听着，我在威尔士很受欢迎。哦，他在把自己推销成吉祥物。
Hold on, guys. Go ahead. I'm just saying that that for a fee or it's all except Bitcoin or food. Maybe you can just pay him in food all day. Feed him in salad. Yeah, carefully. You just spit on your mic. Clear your salads and burgers. Wales is a tremendous country. And I know that you guys are in the northeast of Wales, right?
等等，伙计们。继续。我只是说，只要付酬劳，或者它全盘接受比特币或食物。也许你可以整天用食物付他工钱。用沙拉喂他。对，小心点。你刚才朝麦克风吐口水了。清理好你的沙拉和汉堡。威尔士是个了不起的国家。我知道你们在威尔士的东北部，对吧？
Like not too far from Liverpool. Don't you have a writer on your staff? I know a guy I follow Humphrey. Is that his name? Yes. And he's a big Liverpool supporter as well. Isn't he? He's not only a Liverpool supporter. He's what got me into football in the first place.
离利物浦不太远。你们员工里是不是有个作家？我认识一个我关注的叫汉弗莱的人。是叫这个名字吗？是的。他也是个狂热的利物浦球迷，对吧？他不仅是个利物浦球迷。他就是当初把我领进足球世界的人。
OK. And I and I named him. He's now the director of football operations at Rexham. No way. Yes. The way that I'm going to entice Jason to come to watch a game in north Wales is by is to tell him that it is probably a 20 minute helicopter ride slash private plane from there to Royal County down. Oh, that's a golf course. That's a golf course for for tracing Wisconsin.
好的。而且我，我给他取了名。他现在是雷克萨姆足球运营总监。没门。是的。我诱使杰森去北威尔士看球的方式，就是告诉他从那儿坐直升机或私人飞机到皇家县大概只要20分钟。哦，那是高尔夫球场。那是为威斯康星州的崔西准备的高尔夫球场。
So, Will, I've got that at a 45 minute salad already and you're probably not even done. Still going. Go ahead. Try to say something right now. Go ahead. Speak. Hi. No. God. Sorry. Go ahead, Rob.
所以，威尔，我已经拿到了45分钟的沙拉时间，而且你可能还没吃完。还在继续。继续。现在试着说点什么。继续。说话。嗨。不。天哪。抱歉。继续，罗布。
Rob, I want to apologize to you. Yeah, I will say that it was on the schedule. And it was on the schedule. Yeah, there was a fuck up in my timing. But you know, it's not up on you, right? In fact, we pushed it a little bit because I had some technical difficulties here. Here's the thing. Here's the thing, Rob.
罗布，我想向你道歉。是的，我会说这在日程安排上。这确实在日程安排上。是的，我的时间安排搞砸了。但你知道，这不怪你，对吧？事实上，我们稍微推迟了一点，因为我这里遇到了一些技术困难。事情是这样的。事情是这样的，罗布。
Most a lot of people could take that and I can see that. And first of all, let me apologize. But here's why I don't feel like I should apologize because I could see some people who don't know me or if I don't know them, would take umbrage with the fact that I was eating during the interview. However, because I consider you a friend,
大多数很多人都能接受这一点，我明白这一点。首先，让我道个歉。但这就是为什么我觉得我不应该道歉，因为我看出有些人不认识我，或者如果我不认识他们，会对我采访时吃东西这件事感到冒犯。然而，因为我视你为朋友，
I figured that you wouldn't mind. And I feel very comfortable because I like you a lot and I think that you like me. And so I figured like, he'll be okay with it. That sounds exactly like the excuse that I would give. I know. And it's legit. It's legit.
我想你不会介意。而且我感到非常自在，因为我很喜欢你，而且我想你也喜欢我。所以我想，他会不介意的。这听起来完全像我会找的借口。我知道。而且这很合理。这很合理。
It's a declaration of comfort and intimacy to go ahead and have a full meal while you're interviewing somebody. I wish at this point, given our conversation and I wish and I just can't, I also wish I could come out. Oh, here we go. But I can, I'm not gay.
在采访别人时大吃大喝，这是舒适和亲密的宣言。我希望在这一点上，鉴于我们的对话，我希望，我也不能，我也希望我能出柜。哦，来吧。这是给你的音乐，罗布。没关系。我他妈希望我能。我们很支持。不，我是认真的。我还以为你要说，我希望我也点了一份甜点。不，我只是希望我能出柜。
That's a music for you, Rob. That's okay. I fucking wish I could. We're supportive. No, I'm serious. I thought you were gonna say, I wish that I had ordered dessert as well. No, I just wish I could come out.
Rob, how did you agree with that assessment of Will's that it's okay to eat in front of friends like that?
Rob, how did you agree with that assessment of Will's that it's okay to eat in front of friends like that? I suppose so. I mean, it's the thing where I've laughed the most about over the course of the podcast as far. So I believe I suppose it's good for Bits. All right, good. It's good for Bits.
I suppose so. I mean, it's the thing where I've laughed the most about over the course of the podcast as far. So I believe I suppose it's good for Bits. All right, good. It's good for Bits.
Well, Rob, thank you for being here. This has been just wonderful. That's it? Well, hang on. No, I don't think we're done yet. We're not quite done yet with Rob. I also do want to know, I do want to know because you,
with the football, right? We don't say so. We say we have to say football. So the football team, and you seem to just really light up when you're talking about all that business side, where are you as far as passion with the art of and the craft of acting?
Or do you see yourself in the future more going that way? Oh, I thought it was going for the passion of football, which I actually would like to address for a second because I've heard Mr. Arnett talk about his new found passion for Formula One racing. And I'd like to say that like, when I bring this up to Americans or American audiences, obviously this football is the biggest sport in the world.
And yet it doesn't still have a passionate American fan base. And there's a lot of different reasons as to why I've heard people, which just sound like excuses to me, in the same way that there's not a lot of passion for Formula One racing. However, there is passion for NASCAR,
just not in our particular Hollywood bubble. That said, I think that once you are- I live in Beverly Hills, thank you very much. Yes, I know. I think that as we all know, when you're exposed to something new, which by the way is a common theme of this, that seems to be the theme of this particular episode.
When you're exposed to something new and you're open to it, open to the possibilities, and if the story is told correctly, then you realize that the thing itself, the sport itself, becomes irrelevant in the same way that like who gives a shit about who can put a ball on a hoop or who can, the story is what's most important,
is that you get invested in the club, you get invested in the team, you get invested in the human beings who are behind, who are on the pitch, who are on the court, who are in the cars, and then that's what you become. You're right, the same thing with Formula One. Once I watched that series on Netflix
and I got hooked into the story of these guys, yeah. But Sean, to your other question about like, am I pushing in that direction to get away from the entertainment business side of it or the acting side of it? No, because as we all, everybody on this podcast knows that the acting is the easiest part and the funnest part. Yeah, for sure.
I think it's just so much more. You have an entrepreneurial spirit though, right? Yes. And you're enjoying sort of, I think it's great. All right, back to the show. Rob, you're gonna have to get these guys, maybe you can send some DVDs of all your work so we can all celebrate you even more in your work.
I'd settle for a t-shirt from the soccer team. I mean, let's- I'm gonna get your hat, you can wear out on the course or out to hide your face. I'm gonna get you guys some links to some stuff, that Bill's already seen. Well, he doesn't mean sausage links. Yeah, no, some links to some episodes of various things.
By the way, how good would that go down right now? We're up to that salad. Sausage link from Rexham. I will say that Jason has seen something that I've done. And that was because we were hanging out one time and I said to him, and this was, again, maybe I'm starting this by blowing smoke up Jason's ass, but I'm at the risk of sounding, yes.
Don't worry, his ass is charred from the smoke. My Rexham is up and ready right now, go ahead. I will say that there's a generation of comedic actors or at least acting style that is very modeled after a Bateman kind of look on life. That sounds overstated. I see. I would defer and say it's modeled after your co-owner,
Ryan Reynolds. Honestly, he would say the same about you and he did say the same about you, which is interesting. But I do notice sometimes myself, if I'm watching myself in the editing room, I'm like, oh, I'm trying to do what Jason Bateman does, but I'm not doing it as well. And then so I told Jason about this and he was like,
oh, that sounds good, I'd like to see that. So I clipped out some of it and I sent it to him and I said, this is me basically trying to do you and I only recognize this in retrospect. And he wrote back very complimentary things. Now, yes. About his, about your performance, like this, not unlike his. Well, he said, this doesn't seem like me
because of course it wouldn't to him, but he said it is really funny. Now, but yet still very funny. And by the way, watch that right away. He watched that one real quick. Yeah, I pulled the bar over. The response time, I mean, the clip was, I don't know, 35 seconds long
and the response was 38 seconds. Yeah, of course, of course it was. That sounds nice. That sounds wow. Nevertheless, I was legitimately flying again at the risk of ruining your show with sincerity. You're damn funny. You can tell, you can tell just playing golf with the fella.
You guys are all, you know, from an older generation, of course. I grew up watching you. I grew up watching you all and you're all big influences on us. Now, where are you in your incredibly busy year? You're resting slightly, you're after the... Post-press.
Eric Bragg is the character you're playing on the Amazon show. Mystic show. And then you're about to start directing Never Cloudy in Jersey, is it? On the... Yeah, we're getting there. You're resting right now, right?
Well, we start writing Sunny week after next, season 15. But we did, we are in the middle of releasing Mythic Quest season two right now, which, you know, you guys aren't gonna bring it up, so I will. 100% on Rotten Tomatoes. Thank you. Yeah, thank you.
No, I said that certified, certified fresh, yeah, incredible. 100%. Yeah, that's great. Yes, which, you know, I, if the reviews are bad, of course, we don't, we don't speak of them. You don't mention them, no, of course.
You don't mention them a little bit. If they're good, then they're, then they're, these are the smartest. And the second season's about to come out. These are the smartest. The second season, we are in the middle of releasing the second season. That's great.
The second season, Jason's not hearing any of it. Yeah, I love the question. The second season's coming out. Okay, so that, there's another one that I don't need to watch. The fucking confusion. He has resting confusion face. Look at that.
It's just so, and it's masked as anger, but it's really underneath. It's just a fucking swirl of confusion. I told you, I lost control of my brow. The fifth episode is of the season is going to be airing. Well, this week, that doesn't make any sense. Yes, we are, we are in the middle of. You've direct, you've, you've directed a bunch
of those that you did, not all of them, but you've like two or three in the first season and a couple of this season. Is that right? That's right. You like, you like that part of it. You, you, you like directing more than the acting. I love, I love the, putting the pieces together
of something difficult and it's just a new, it's just a new challenge. I mean, don't get me wrong. I love showing up and saying, and just saying words while cameras pointed at me. Yeah. And then just, and then rapping and going home and taking none of it home with you. Yes. That's fun.
That's very fun. But I also do, I just love the whole filmmaking process. I, I love, I love being asked a million questions a day. I think that's just really fun. Are you going to be involved in any of the creative decisions on the, on the doc for the, for the soccer team? No, so I, I actively decided against that. I wanted to make sure,
because I also just felt like it would be unfair to the documentary and it would just wind up seem, seeming masturbatory, honestly, that I wanted to be somewhat objective. I want the doc documentary to be objective. So we hired the documentarians that made chef's table. They made cheer. They made last chance use.
Oh, great. They're great. They're a great series that I love. Yeah. And basically, I just said, good luck, show me, show me a cut. If there's something like egregious where I truly look like a douchebag, I will be honest. It'll be hard for me not to at least give him up.
Yeah, but that'll be compelling, compelling television. However, I want to, I want to stay objective. So I want the documentary to stay objective. So I'm going to stay out of it as much as I can. I wouldn't know. What about Ryan? Is he going to get in there? He's a monster.
He's an egomaniac monster. So he's going to be in the avid. And he's all hopped up on Jen too. Like you can't stop him. He'll, he'll fight you. He gets all on Jen. He's a hopped up on Jen. He's looking for a reception on his mobile network that he owns.
I mean, this guy, he's got his hands in everything, you know? God, he's handsome. He's aging so gracefully, isn't he? He's so handsome and funny. So fucking nice. You got him beat in the skin department. Fucking sincere. I do?
I don't know. You look so hydrated today. Look at that skin. Good skin. Thanks. Rob, thank you so much for being here today. We've learned so much about you. Look at the teeth too.
Look how white those are. God damn it. I don't drink coffee, Jason. I think that's what, yes. Look, we, I, you guys have learned so much about me. I have learned nothing about you because I know so much about you all. You get one question.
You get one question. You know, Will likes to eat. Well, I'll say I am fascinated with, with Jason. Well, I don't know how personally you want to get Jason. You seem to hold everybody at arms length. No, roll it out, roll it out. Well, there's obviously a, there's obviously an armor that's been built up,
which is the source of his entire persona. It's a soft candy shell. Keep going, keep going. But I know everything about his family life, just because I ask him questions and I'm interested in it. And I think maybe at some point, you guys, maybe not now, it's not appropriate, but you could do a deep dive into Jason's childhood,
这就是他整个人设的来源。它外面是一层软糖外壳。继续说，继续说。但我对他 的家庭生活了如指掌，只是因为我问了他问题，而且我对这很感兴趣。我觉得也许在某 个时候，伙计们，也许不是现在，现在不太合适，但你们可以深入了解一下杰森的童年，
into his relationship with his various family members, his parents, cause it is, it is, it is actually fascinating. Not a lot of people know I have multiple families. We don't have enough tissue for that episode, but this way. Okay. No, Rob, I've got, that was fascinating to learn about your mothers. I actually do, I want to follow up on all of that
了解他与各位家庭成员、他父母的关系，因为这其实、其实、其实真的很迷人。 没多少人知道我有好几个家庭。那一集纸巾可不够用，不过这样也行。好吧。不，罗布 ，我——了解你的母亲们真的太迷人了。我其实确实想跟进所有这些事情，
when we get back out on the course. That is the one good thing, one of the many good things of playing golf. You can have a nice four hour conversation with a buddy. Same thing with going to a Dodger game, you know? I like that. Or a doctor's appointment. Or this, this is the only time I talk with friends.
当我们重新回到球场上时。这是打高尔夫球的一个好处，众多好处之一。你可以 和朋友进行一次长达四个小时的美妙谈话。去道奇队比赛也是一样，你知道吗？我喜欢 那个。或者去预约看医生。或者这个，这是我唯一和朋友们聊天的时间。
It's on this one hour, or at the Dodger game, or on the golf course. Have you noticed the thing where Jason likes about all those things? He likes to be able to not have to look at you while he talks. And then that's the only way he'd be intimate. Cause there's an activity involved.
就在这一个小时里，或者在道奇队的比赛中，或者在高尔夫球场上。你注意到杰 森喜欢所有这些事情的一个特点了吗？他喜欢在说话时不用看着你。然后这是他唯一能 表现得亲密的方式。因为其中涉及一项活动。
Pop in and pop out. He's the only way he can be intimate is if he's not looking at you, which is why he and Amanda, well, anyway, it doesn't matter. Okay, so let's just say they can both, they can both watch the game. His two girls really are a miracle. And they're gorgeous.
说来就来，说走就走。他唯一能表现得亲密的方式就是他不看着你，这就是为什么 他和阿曼达——好吧，不管怎样，没关系。好吧，那么我们只能说他们俩都可以，他们 俩都可以看比赛。他的两个女孩真的是个奇迹。而且她们美极了。
And they really are, it really is a miracle. Rob, thank you so much for coming out, man. Fucking the best. You're the best. Thank you. I'm a massive fan of all of you guys individually and a massive fan of the podcast as is apparently most of America.
而且她们真的是，这真的个奇迹。罗布，非常感谢你能来，老兄。他妈的太棒了 。你最棒了。谢谢。我是你们所有人的超级粉丝，也是这个播客的超级粉丝，正如美利 坚绝大多数人一样。
So thank you for having me. You're a mega talent. You're a mega talent. And we're honored. It's nice of you to do this, truly. And give your love to your moms for me and your whole family. We'll do it.
所以谢谢你邀请我。你是个超级天才。你是个超级天才。我们感到很荣幸。你真 人太好了，真的。替我向你的妈妈们和你的全家问好。我们会这么做的。
Thank you so much. You think you meant to say, give my love. You mean give your love, not him. Sorry. I give my love to them. He gives his love to you all the time. And give my love to your moms and your whole family. With his love?
非常感谢。你以为你想说的是，代我向他们问好。你的意思是代你向他们问好，而 不是他。抱歉。我代我向他们问好。他一直都代他向你问好。代我向你的妈妈们和你的全 家问好。带着他的问候？
I will. Okay. Rob, I love you. Thank you. I love you too, Rob. I love you guys. Bye, Rob. Bye-bye.
我会的。好吧。罗布，我爱你。谢谢。我也爱你，罗布。我也爱你们。再见，罗 布。拜拜。
Bye. What a great guy. That great guy. That great guy. Jason, you introduced me to him. Yup. And when he emailed me, like I said at the beginning, I didn't know him.
再见。多好的人啊。那真是个好人。多好的人啊。杰森，是你把我介绍给他的。对 呀。当他给我发邮件时，就像我一开始说的，我不认识他。
And now after talking to him, you go, oh, this is the, this is one of those guys with those personalities that you go, oh, I could hang out with him all day long. Yeah. And Rodin created two super successful shows. Like doing one is a huge feat. He's done it again. And I'm sure he'll do it again.
现在跟聊过之后，你会觉得，哦，这就是那种人，那些你一接触就会觉得，哦 ，我可以跟他一整天都待在一起的性格。对呀。而且罗布创作了两个超级成功的节目。 就像做成一个就已经是个壮举了。他又做到了。而且我确信他还会再做到的。
He's just one of those guys. He's so talented. And I love that he just picked up the, like Jason said, on an off Wednesday, went to go pick up a camera and just started filming the thing. Like that's, I love that kind of advice to younger folks who are trying to like, what do I do? How do I become an actor?
他就是那种人。他太有才华了。我喜欢他就像杰森说的，在一个调休的周三，去 拿了台摄像机就开始拍东西。我就喜欢这种给年轻人的建议，他们正试图弄清楚——我 该做些什么？我该怎么成为一名演员？
How do I get into the business? Just pick up a camera and go and just start shooting stuff. And he did it. I think his kindness is infectious. I do love hanging out with him. Love him. He's great. You know, the thing, Rob is one of those guys,
我怎么进入这个行业？拿起摄像机去拍，然后开始拍东西就行了。而且他做到了 。我觉得他的亲和力很有感染力。我确实很喜欢跟他待在一起。很喜欢他。他太棒了。 你知道吗，罗布就是那种人，
I enjoy him more and more. The more time I spend with him, the more I enjoy him and the more I like him. You're implying you didn't really like him much at the beginning. No, I'm saying that I didn't, when I didn't really know him, I didn't know him. And then I liked him immediately.
我越来越喜欢他。我花在他身上的时间越多，我就越欣赏他，也越喜欢他。你这是 在暗示你一开始其实不太喜欢他咯？不，我的意思是，当我真的不了解他时，我是不认识 他。然后我马上就喜欢上他了。
And then I like him increasingly. It's just sort of- Yeah, I don't know him. He's a magnet. Yeah. Yeah, I feel like I would really enjoy, or it's always sunny, you know? Cause I love him and I love Charlie.
然后我越来越喜欢他。这就像是——对呀，我不了解他。他就像个磁铁。对呀。 对呀，我觉得我会真的很喜欢，或者总是艳阳高照，你知道吗？因为我爱他，我也爱查 理。
The whole cast is great, you know? So I should just start watching. You like to deprive yourself of certain things too, don't you? I just feel like there's so many things I haven't, I don't know where to start. I mean, we'll talk about it in the episode. I've never seen ER, never seen West Wing,
整个演员阵容都很棒，你知道吗？所以我应该开始看。你也很喜欢剥夺自己享受某 些事情的权利，不是吗？我只是觉得有太多事情我还没看过，我都不知道该从哪里开始 。我的意思是，我们会在这一集里谈到。我从来没看过《急诊室的故事》，没看过《白 宫风云》，
never seen Dallas, or your favorite show, Falcon Crest. Well, I've never seen one single episode of that. It was out forever, you know? Or Battlestar Galactica, like where do I, like Gunsmoke, I never saw. So where do I start, man? Gunsmoke is in the fucking 60s. Well, I know, but come on, I haven't, you know,
没看过《达拉斯》，或者你最喜欢的节目《鹰冠庄园》。好吧，我连其中单单一 集都没看过。它播了超级久，你知道吗？或者《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》，我该从哪里—— 就像《荒野大镖客》，我从来没看过。所以我从哪里开始呢，老兄？《荒野大镖客》 可是他妈的上世纪60年代的剧。
I've never seen Soap, you know, one of the classic comedy- Ooh, that was a very good show. That was a very good show, you know? So- There's a lot of movies- There's tons of movies I haven't seen, exactly, you know? What, hey, you know what?
好吧，我知道，但是拜托，我还没——你知道的，我从来没看过《肥皂剧》，你 知道吗，经典喜剧之一——噢，那是一部非常好的剧。那是一部非常好的剧，你知道吗 ？所以——有很多电影——有大量我没看过的电影，没错，你知道吗？什么，嘿，你 知道吗？
I've never known that. What is, Jason, you go first. What's your favorite movie of all time, currently? Just one, just one. 2001. Really? Yeah. Yep.
我从来不知道这个。什么是——杰森，你先来。你目前历来最喜欢的电影是什么 ？就一部，就一部。2001太空漫游。真的吗？对呀。没错。
It was just dry enough. It was just slow and dry enough. I mean, I- Well, what's your favorite movie of all time? I know I'm asking you, I asked you first. Me? Amadeus. Of course I have, for God's sake.
它刚好足够干巴巴。它的节奏刚好足够慢、足够干巴巴。我的意思是，我——好 吧，你历来最喜欢的电影是什么？我知道我在问你，我先问的你。我？阿玛迪斯。我当 然看过，看在上帝的份上。
Yeah. What's yours, Will? I will go there. Mine has been for a long time with Neil and I. Oh, that's right. That's right. Which Rob said. But I didn't know Rob until today, obviously.
对呀。你的是什么，威尔？我来回答。我和尼尔很久以来一直都是。哦，对哦 。对哦。罗布是这么说的。但我直到今天才认识罗布，显然。
Favorite band of all time. Okay. Led Zeppelin. Probably because I'm super gay, erasure. Hang on a second. Hang, hang, hang on. Or Depeche Mode. Wait a second.
历来最喜欢的乐队。好吧。齐柏林飞艇。可能是因为我超级基，伊瑞瑟（Erasure ）。等一下。等，等，等一下。或者赶路者（Depeche Mode）。等一下。
You're gonna leave Bronski beat out there? I'm not Bronski beat. And the smooths. Run away, turn away, run away, run away, turn away. Hang on, wait a second. Eurasia. Erasure. Erasure.
你打算把布朗斯基beat（Bronski Beat）漏掉吗？我不是布朗斯基beat。还有 斯穆兹乐队（The Smiths）。逃离吧，转身吧，逃离吧，逃离吧，转身吧。等等，等 一下。伊瑞瑟。伊瑞瑟。伊瑞瑟。
Erasure. Like that's at the end of a pencil? Listen, listen. What are they saying? You know, I tried to discover a little something to make me sweet. Never heard of it. That you gave me no, that you gave me no,
伊瑞瑟。就像铅笔头上那种吗？听着，听着。他们在唱什么？你知道，我试着发 现一点能让我变甜蜜的东西。从没听说过。你没给我，你没给我，
that you gave me no, that you gave me no, never heard of it before in my life. Why do you know it? My favorite, maybe of all time, might be the Smiths. Okay. The Smiths, same. That's my favorite. One of my favorites.
你没给我，你没给我，我这辈子从来没听说过。你为什么知道它？我历来最喜欢 的，也许是史密斯乐队。好吧。史密斯乐队，一样。那是我的最爱。我的最爱之一。
You know, my daughter, my 14 year old daughter's really into the Smiths. And I said, I made a suggestion of a like sort of sounding band. Tell me if I was wrong here. Bell and Sebastian. You ever heard of them? No.
你知道，我女儿，我14岁的女儿真的很迷史密斯乐队。我说，我推荐了一个听起 来有点像的乐队。看看我这里有没有猜错。贝儿与塞巴斯蒂安（Bell and Sebastian ）。你听说过他们吗？没有。
Many times. Yeah, I made a little mix tape of that the other day or a playlist, I think, as well. I don't know them. I gotta check on them. Oh, they're great. Oh, they're so good. In fact, I'll send you the playlist.
很多次。对呀，我前几天做了一点那个的小混音带，或者播放列表，我想，也是 。我不认识他们。我得去查查看。哦，他们很棒。哦，他们太棒了。事实上，我会把播放 列表发给你。
Stuart Murdock, who's the lead singer of Bell and Sebastian, and I had a great dialogue a few years ago because I got him to give us a song for Flaked. And I got to know a lot of bands through putting the music together for the show. You know, they say that Flaked, one of the best or probably the best soundtrack in all of television history.
斯图尔特·默多克（Stuart Murdock），他是贝儿与塞巴斯蒂安的主唱，几年前 我们有过一次很好的对话，因为我让他为《随性所欲》（Flaked）给我们写了一首歌 。通过为这部剧整理音乐，我认识了很多乐队。你知道，他们说《随性所欲》是电视 史上最好的或是可能是最好的原声带。
That's according to NME. Flaked is the show that Weld did on Netflix. That's according to NME magazine. I don't know. I didn't say it. They did. They said potentially the best soundtrack in TV history. Again.
那是根据NME（新音乐快递）的说法。《随性所欲》是威尔在Netflix上制作的 节目。那是根据NME杂志的说法。我不知道。我没这么说。是他们说的。他们说这可能 是电视史上最好的原声带。再说一次。
It looks weird. It's them, not you saying, you know. And it wasn't written by me. It was written by them. And by them. Did that work? That worked. Do it again.
这看起来很怪。是他们在说，而不是你在说，你知道。而且这不是我写的。这是 他们写的。而且是由他们写的。那样管用吗？那样管用。再来一次。
Kind of. It did sneak up on me. I know. It was a little sneaky. You could have framed it up better. Go ahead. We're still rolling. Try it again.
差不多吧。它确实悄悄地袭向了我。我知道。这有点偷偷摸摸的。你本可以把它构 思得更好。继续。我们还在录音。再试一次。
It wasn't written by me. The worst part is I gotta say it first one. Yeah, exactly. It wasn't written by me. It was written by them. By them. Right. So Sean, do you want to try one?
这不是我写的。最糟糕的部分是我得先说第一句。对，没错。这不是我写的。这 是他们写的。由他们写的。对。所以肖恩，你想试一个吗？
You're trying. We're really off our game today. Well, Rob really knocked us out, you know? I mean, the guy is just, he hit us with the charm and the teeth and the hydrated skin. I think that all his success really comes from. You could almost say it's a bye, product. Bye, product, bye, product.
你在试。我们今天真的不在状态。好吧，罗布真的把我们给镇住了，你知道吗？ 我的意思是，这家伙就是，他用魅力、白牙和水润的皮肤向我们袭来。我想他所有的成 就真的都来源于此。你几乎可以说这是一个副产品。副产品，副产品。
No, I think. Here's what I think. God, that was so great. This is the clumsiest landing we've ever had. Yeah, keep going. I don't have it. I don't have it. I don't have it.
不，我想。我是这么想的。天哪，那太棒了。这是我们经历过最笨拙的着陆了。 对，继续。我接不上。我接不上。我接不上。
You know what? Can we just get back to, no. You know what I want to do? Here it comes, here it comes. Let's just get back to a real simple old school like we did in the old days, which was just, bye. Well, how about you start with, guys? I really enjoyed my time with you today.
你知道吗？我们能回到——不。你知道我想做什么吗？它来了，它来了。让我们 回到那种非常简单、老派的风格，就像我们以前那样，也就是，再见。好吧，你怎么不 从这个开始：伙计们？我很享受今天和你们在一起的时光。
I hope you have a great rest of the Sunday. And listen, just to sincere, goodbye. Bye. See you tomorrow. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
希望你们周日剩下的时间过得愉快。听着，就说真诚的，再见。再见。明天见。 这一集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。